we have been asked to multiply 41 with
13 using lines we have already seen how
this technique works for the digit 1 we
draw one line for the digit 2 we draw
two lines and so on the first digit of
the number 41 is 4 so we draw four lines
and for the second digit one we draw one
line after leaving some space for 13 we
draw one line for one and three lines
for three don't forget in each case we
went from left to right and the three
vertical zones are ready we start with a
zone at the extreme right and count the
number of intersections one two and
three three intersections
now for the second zone from the right
at the top we can see that there are 12
intersections and there's one at the
bottom 13 and all but wait what do we do
when we get two digits under a zone we
simply carry the tens digit over to the
column on the left yes that's all here
we carry the one over and now if we look
at the final zone there are four
intersections we add the four to the one
that was carried over and that gives us
five that's the answer
41 times 13 gives us 533 that was so
simple lines from left to right and
count the intersections in each zone the
next problem is a bit tricky
211 x 32 we have a three digit number
here does anything change well not much
the approach is the same but the number
of zones change two lines four to one
line for one and another line for one
this is two one one what about 32 three
lines for three and two lines for - how
many vertical zones do you see there's
one two three and four for vertical
zones this time the process remains
unchanged though we start with a zone at
the extreme right two intersections we
write a two then we move on to the
second zone - at the top and three
at the bottom five in all now pause the
video and try finding the number of
intersections in these two zones this is
the third zone for intersections at the
top and three at the bottom seven and
all and this is the fourth zone which
has six intersections we write a six
here and we are done this is the product
211 times 32 gives us 6752
by now you'd be pretty confident of
using this technique for multiplication
but sometimes this method may not work
when does it not work take the next
example for instance 53 times 36
wait don't draw the lines this is how
the figure will look the black lines for
53 and the red ones for 36 finally the
number of intersections would be very
tedious in this case it gets very messy
when any of the digits of 5 or greater
so this method is suited for numbers
which have digits lesser than 5 but if
we really have to solve such an example
using this technique there is a better
way which we will cover in the next part
and look at these two questions how
would you solve these how would you draw
a line for 0 we covered this as well in
the next part of the session